en israël comme on s'y attendait un peu
c'est shimon pérès le numéro un du parti
travailliste qui est chargé de former le
futur gouvernement ne sait pas encore
s'il s'agira d'un cabinet d'union
nationale ou au contraire d'un cabinet
de majorité des restreinte le portrait
de shimon peres par didier epelbaum
shimon peres 61 ans il attendait ça
depuis dix une carrière particulièrement
dense paint ball yonne le fondateur de
l'état le nomme à 29 ans directeur
général du ministère de la défense
vice ministre de la défense pendant dix
ans c'est lui qui crée les centrales
nucléaires les industries aéronautique
et militaire ministre de la défense
après la guerre de 73 simone perez était
un leader impopulaire la cible de toutes
les attaques de la droite et même de
certains de ses amis politiques il a
finalement su gagner l'estimé du public
par une dure campagne à l'américaine en
question seulement m et volée paper/opa
si vous aimez ce n'est pas un plaisir
je suis très indiquée je suis un homme
d'état brêteau il faut faire le servait
l'état par les partis des parties 7 en
moyenne accueilli souvent par des
tomates
lors de la précédente campagne
électorale shimon peres s'est fait
accepter par les électeurs des quartiers
considérés jusque là comme des places
fortes de la droite
son plus grand succès c'est peut-être
d'avoir obtenu le soutien et la
bénédiction d'une partie importante des
communautés d'origine orientale
le futur premier ministre aura pour
premier objectif de remettre en ordre
les finances du pays
il tentera de relancer le processus de
paix au proche orient
shimon peres a du pain sur la planche
pour réussir il compte aussi sur l'aide
de l'europe et de ses amis de
l'internationale socialiste